welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and batman v superman donna justice
is
a lot of movie some might say too big
for little minds
three hours of it if you're going by
zack snyder's ultimate edition
as we are for this scene by scene
analysis and breakdown of all the
actually cool details snyder and his
team hid throughout this film
because like the closing shot no zack
snyder dream stays buried forever the
film opens with a black casket
reflecting the autumn sky
the weighing funeral which in this
movie's bookended by superman's black
casket in the closing shot which is
based on his silver shield on black
resurrection suit in the comics snyder
also features a close-up on a slo-mo
smokey casein in both deaths because
both of them are a death in bruce's
family
superman in this film tells him to bury
it and burying people is really all
bruce does
the cinema shows a poster for the mark
of zorro with wayne's death classically
outside of zorro showing to
inspire bruce's future as a black mask
vigilante but here it's excalibur
batman v superman in many ways is a
story of arthur and lancelot
rivals who team up against a common foe
that won defeats via self-impalement
the mugger's gun snapping martha's beat
of pearls is lifted directly from frank
miller's the dark knight returns
snyder's primary comic influence
jeffrey dean morgan and lauren kohan
themselves rivals from the walking dead
play the slain thomas and we will get to
that safe word
i do love how one of martha's pearls
drops with bruce
later after he falls into the cave
suggesting that he kept one of her
pearls from that murder and clung to it
during the funeral bruce does
clutches pearls every time superman
breaks the city the wanton destruction
of man of steel's final act is reframed
with grounded empathy
as bruce watches innocent suffer and
this battle is actually
synced perfectly the reigning debris
that bruce glares up at is his own
wane satellite that zod threw down in
previous movie and
in the dust bruce first sees a horse
equine imagery recurs throughout this
film
galloping through the streets to warn us
while i ate my hero cake their horses
were drowning but there are actually
four appearances by
live horses this one in metropolis and
then later outside the capitol
and then the two sets of horses
escorting supermans and clark's caskets
each horse bringing death and snyder
acknowledged this four horsemen of the
apocalypse parallel as being intentional
this extended director's cut outright
reveals lois's colleague as
jimmy olsen photographer actually a cia
mall who doesn't last long
anatoly kanayazev aka caps attempted
murder and winter soldier
is the villain kg beast in the comics
kahin aziri testifies for senator finch
the world has been so caught up with
what superman can do
that no one has asked what he should do
invoking my man dr ian malcolm but your
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop to think if they should
got gotham cops watched metropolis state
running up the score on gotham city
the way superman runs up the hero score
on gotham's hero
actually cyborg actor ray fisher
confirmed gotham lost
because their star player victor stone
was out due to injury
and the dispatcher calls charlie 27
delta's charlie 27 and now to dc
detective comics
issue 27 the comic debut of batman and
in the streets of gotham they passed a
sign for joker's favorite bathhouse ace
chemicals
which shows up throughout this movie and
in pretty much every dceu movie forward
bruce meets alfred in the bat cave
funnel fairy butterball funnel fairy
butterball funnel ferry there's nothing
wrong with the microphone
this batman uses a voice modulator a
practical advancement for a famous
billionaire to avoid his voice getting
recognized
and alfred says you don't even know if
he exists it could be a phantasm
perhaps a nod to manny's top batman
animated film mask of the phantasm but
then alfred stokes that paranoia
innocents die that's how it starts
the fever the rage the feeling of
powerlessness that turns good man
cruel god damn jeremy irons can deliver
a line but
audio mix is also great here between the
han zimmer junkie xl
new on edge batman theme there's a
little scream
echoing after innocents die innocents
die
as we talked about last week man of
steel was an immigrant story the sequel
flips that narrative to the other side
of that the suspicious
old-timer who believes his turf is now
threatened by the newcomer
get off melania alien and these opening
scenes do a great job making this story
about
fear of the newcomer and that dual
narrative is reflected in the two cities
media
metropolis's daily planet writes puff
pieces about superman's heroics here the
gotham free press glorifies the bat
brand of justice
though later bruce suggests that i think
he owns this paper daily plan
wait do i own this one where's that the
other guy and then we made
it's cherry
jesse eisenberg's take on lex luthor is
polarizing but that might be because
eisenberg was actually impersonating
someone
screenwriter and similarly polarizing
figure max landis
with whom eisenberg had just worked on
american ultra and landis himself said
that he saw the parallel and others said
that iceberg's later line was an exact
mimicry of something they heard landis
say
i love it i love bringing people
together how are we on wally keeps crazy
research wall is a depiction of superman
lived in a car
just like in his famous first appearance
in action comics number one bruce tracks
can is up to an underground fighting
ring good luck for one is always
his brother's misfortune the little
foreshadowing for bruce's lucky survival
of doomsday at the misfortune of his
brother
lex shows his dad's painting to the
senator that should be upside down
the devils don't come from hell beneath
us no
no they come from the sky and in the
final minutes after his rest lex
actually does flip this painting upside
down
reflecting the devils from the sky that
are now thanks to him
approaching and bruce's graveyard is a
headstone to the right
which if you zoom in enhance or look at
set photos is the headstone of
one richard grayson whose robin suit is
kept in the batcave with graffiti
implying that joker had killed him
bruce alludes to this later we just have
a bad history with
freaks dressed like clowns suicide squad
confirmed that harley quinn had a role
in this as well
recently snyder did confirm that that
suit was that of dick grace and not
jason todd like in the death of the
family comics
though there are a number of theories
that the dceu joker jared leto could
have been a converted
tim drake based on an interesting line
later 20 years in gotham alfred
how many good guys are left how many
stayed that way suggesting that many
past allies whether they're dents or
kyles or robins
might have turned corrupt over the years
now listen closely as bruce walks into
the crypt
that sounds familiar that's the
kryptonian world engine for the black
zero event
now this sound haunts bruce for all the
lives that were lost on that day
every time he dreams you can hear it in
the background
now the stained glass behind them
depicts the archangel michael casting
lucifer down to hell
michael is in red and blue here
superman's colors surrounding him are
the flaming skyscrapers like those in
metropolis
so in this metaphor bruce would be the
hell demon demon that jumps out at him
like lex he sees this biblical art as
upside down and then at lex's party our
first look at diana prince is scored
with a subtle riff of our wonder woman
theme
open bar lex references greek mythology
prometheus went with us
and he ruined zeus's plan to destroy
mankind and for that he was given a
thunderbolt
to diana this is not myth zeus is her
father the governor of new jersey at
this party is a cameo by michigan
senator debbie stabenow they did shoot
most of this movie in michigan vermont
senator pat lee actually cameos at the
senate hearing he cameos in nearly every
batman film the dia de los muertos
celebrator's skull makeup reflects
superman drowning in the skulls and man
of steel
this kind of worship is similarly
smothering to him clarke reads an
article about batman's brands being a
death sentence at blackgate and at the
bottom of the paragraph the quote
who watches the watchmen is a nod to
snyder's previous film watchmen actually
the original latin version of the phrase
shows up as graffiti later
and in that article the quote is from
harvey
probably dent a little setup for too
faced in the dcu lex gives keith the
rigged wheelchair on the table he's
playing some cards if you look closely
at the top right
pretty sure that is the three of clubs a
calling card by director photography
larry fong
who hides it in many of his films enrico
de la vega on twitter you challenged me
to find it and while the mail might be
screwed i deliver
perry white and clark argue about
journalist ethics when the planet was
founded it stood for something perry
so could you if it was 1938 but it's not
1938.
1938 was of course superman's first
comic appearance though in that issue it
was not the daily planet yet it was the
daily star
diana has shown the sword of alexander
that cut the gordian nut but the angle
reflects the background there bruce
wayne sneaking up on them
a modern alexander the great trying to
cut through his own impossible gordian
knots
onto the nightmare behind bruce are the
even more ruined ruins of wayne manor
but the foundation still stands birds
stay strong
the burn mark on the dried out riverbed
is the omega symbol of darkseid
and taped onto bruce's gun is a joker
card we see superman loyalist troopers
who awareness sigil superman murders
batman now the exact
meaning of this end of flash's visit for
the past would have been revealed in the
sequel to justice league in which flash
would have likely used time travel to
warn batman to avoid lois death and
prevent superman from going
injustice snyder's justice league recut
will likely shed some light on this
planned future or maybe the upcoming
flash movie might since it seems to be
doing all kinds of crazy flashpoint [ __ ]
very excited for that batman tracks
lexus kryptonite shipment from the
gotham port passing the sign for
nicholson dock company of course for
jack nicholson burton's joker now many
criticized batman in this scene for
firing deadly machine guns but one
detail i like is how his gun trigger was
built over his passenger seat a
customization that must have been added
later
suggesting that like his bat branding
his violent streak is a recent
development brought on by a more violent
destructive world thanks to superman the
ultimate edition also includes
much more of clark investigating
batman's violent vigilantism
so when it leads to this confrontation
it's more logically justified and
satisfying
the bat is dead bury it
tell me do you bleed
i like how superman ripped off the doors
of the batmobile and when batman has to
drive it home you can see he has had to
strap these doors back on the roof ziri
realizes she's being targeted
of course for bob kane batman co-creator
this movie's opening credits for the
first time in a batman film credited
other co-creator bill finger
lex gives his regards before the hearing
mercy you go in and
make sure no one takes my seat mercy
graves is lex's bodyguard in the
animated series later brought in the
comics but a little
devious detail here he tells her to go
inside to save his seat
sacrificing her just to make it seem
like he won't be a no-show
notice throughout the hearing she keeps
turning around to look for him she
doesn't know what's going on
is all by likes to claim lexcorp was
also a victim of the bombing but when
superman enters the cameraman on the
left behind the center is a cameo by
zack snyder himself
he definitely would be among these
cameramen trying to get a shot at the
man of steel
lex somehow let us a jar of granny's
peeps piss on the deus and then boom
lois tries to comfort superman this
means something
yes it does lois because after man of
steel the customers updated for this
movie the weed with kryptonian lettering
that translates to a quote by joseph
campbell where we thought to be alone we
shall be with all the world
meanwhile bruce prepares making
kryptonite smoke grenades and notice the
shells are marked pb
lead the substance that superman cannot
see through it lined keef's wheelchair
bomb
this way superman won't be able to see
ahead of time what's in those rounds
prepared for them which is why he's
later surprised by the green smoke
after catching it later
mountain goes paw kent recounts how his
valiant efforts to redirect floodwaters
ended up drowning the lang family horses
death a dark reflection of that winding
river description of superman's sigil
rivers can bring hope but they can also
destroy bruce meanwhile recounts his
family history to alfred the first
generation
made their fortune trading with the
french pelts and skins
they were hunters yeah little truth he
doesn't linger on the wanes braved the
cold to keep the world warm but now that
bruce lacks that empathy alfred laments
so falls the house of wayne oh scar is
so great and as bruce leaves he walks
through this dead
tangled grass as he did in his dream but
then only in his final shot at the end
of the movie
after gaining empathy for his enemy does
he finally walk on a cleared path
forward but here bruce armors up for the
first time in a bat suit in a movie with
no bat sigil on the chest
because as an authority you can get away
with all kinds of [ __ ] when you're
unmarked
on a nearby column it's graffiti with a
riddler question mark
another column later is marked joe kerr
epitaphs of his
former foes basically batman has drawn
him to a graveyard
lois is taken by kanayazev
the music playing there is cole porter's
every time we say goodbye
which guys have later sings to martha
kent and every time we say goodbye
we die a little lex tells superman
no man in the sky intervened when i was
a boy to deliver me from daddy's fist
and abomination
but later this man in the sky does just
this for lex
delivering him from a fist of his own
abomination but listen as lex brings up
martha
martha
the mother of this soft lullaby is the
same one we heard back when superman's
biological mother lara said goodbye to
him as an infant
[Music]
lex threatens to burn martha kyle's
biological mother died
also consumed by fire now this mom stuff
is compelling but we already have a
separate justified conflict between the
heroes
and in less is more story logic one
motivation plus
one separate motivation doesn't equal a
compounded super motivation
rarely it cancels out into unclear
motivation which is a bummer because
this fight is beautifully
shot beautifully choreographed it just
has this weird unnecessary lex martha
skiing before it that taints it
still the fight is epic inspired from
the art in the dark knight returns
including sonic cannons notice how those
waves blow the puddles away
leaving a slightly drier layer of mud
where the blast had hit
the reason this fight still works is
there are some moments where the
motivation is not martha
it's just fear
fear which is great batman's goal is to
make his enemy feel the same fear he
feels and henry cavill shows that fear
really well the suddenless quiver of his
lip that is why you never cgi over that
mouth
batman nearly kills them but superman
says the safe word save
martha why did you say that
now the intention here is that fear is
only cured by
empathy but i think most people just
read the says oh their moms have the
same name that's what happens when you
bring in a
separate somewhat unrelated motivation
audiences just get overwhelmed and they
lose track of what you're trying to say
meanwhile diana explores lex's email
attachment of the metahuman project
which he conveniently labels with each
of the justice league members logos we
see clips of aquaman silas stone and
star labs used in a mother box to turn
victor into cyborg
and when barry allen the flash foils the
robbery he leaves the milk hanging in
the air for a split second and it drops
about an inch when he re-catches it
batman says martha imaging is showing me
two dozen hostiles on the third floor
why don't i drop you off on the second
great block in here batman began the
movie
lurking high above his targets a devil
from the sky
now he's a demon coming from below but
aspiring upward to do the right thing
which in this case is
murder justified murder but murder but
lex unleashes
your doomsday the building doomsday
throws superman into
shows up still under construction and
justice league the fight moves on to
striker's island
a prison in the dc comics but here is a
literal middle ground
between batman's turf and superman's
turf for them to work together
the battle evokes more imagery from the
dark knight returns in the death of
superman
the images of corpsey superman
recharging the sunlight from the comics
as well as if you look very closely as a
quick frame the lightning behind batman
also famously from the comics
wonder woman arrives and completes the
dc trinity and what i think was
everyone's favorite moment
and together the three take down the
monster with superman making the
heartbreaking little stumble
on his final takeoff weakened from
having to approach this kryptonite spear
and as in the death of superman event
superman slays the beast and himself
with christian
symbolism returning as this christ
figure sacrifices himself now lex is
arrested after communion with
steppenwolf seeking those three mother
boxes
he shaved into his iconic baldy look at
belle reeve prison
the same prison of the suicide squad his
number here is tk421
and on to star wars tk421 why aren't you
at your post but later randomly his
prison number changes
prisoner ac 23 1940. the warden wants to
speak to you so stand to your feet which
is also something that's a nod to action
comics number 23 released in 1940
lex luthor's comic debut i love the
season wordplay to signal to batman he
knows who he is
how it all caves and civilization
on the wane manners out the window caves
in wayne manor got it bottom half of the
planet front page reads batman be
friends superman near the end
no and clark's obituary is well written
article until
if you read it three quarters of the way
through they clearly gave up and just
started repeating the text but the final
shot shows lois's soil starting to rise
just like the soil before superman's
first flight in man of steel but the
detail i like even more the music
kicks into credits with a double
percussion like a heartbeat of a body
alive once more
and there you have it look discovering
these details might not fix all the
issues you have with batman v superman
but it does remind us that
so much craft was put into this that is
worth remembering just as snyder unveils
his vision for justice league join this
discussion on our official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of all the big dc news from
fandom this weekend follow me on
instagram following rockstars and pray
that no one ever looks at you the same
way bruce wayne looked at his broken
porn satellite
you know that's what it was for
[Music]
you